You might hear from a Catholic Orthodox person who says,
oh, our church was founded by Jesus Christ.
Challenge that,
because nowhere in the Bible does it say
that Jesus started the Catholic, Orthodox,
or even Protestant or Baptist churches.
Instead, Jesus started his church.
His church is simply made up of those
who trust in Christ,
even if they've never stepped foot
in a church building in their entire life.
Because the church wasn't built on Peter.
Jesus said, you are Peter,
Petros in Greek,
you are Peter,
and on this rock
I'll build my church.
He didn't say,
on you I'm gonna build my church.
Said, you're Petros
and I'm Petra.
I'm gonna build my church.
Two different words.
And if you read through first Peter, chapter 2,
we see that Peter himself says that the Petra,
the rock on which the church is built on,
is Jesus Christ,
not himself.
If it was built on Peter,
he would have collapsed, it be gone.
But thankfully,
it's built on Jesus Christ
being that solid rock.
And so if you're trusting that Jesus paid for your sin,
you're part of his church,
even if you've never stepped foot
in a church building in your entire life.
But if you're looking for a good church to go to,
and it's good to go to church,
go to one that doesn't teach
it's our sacraments that save us,
our good deeds or our baptism.
Go to a church that teaches it's Jesus Christ
and his death on the cross alone,
that gets us into heaven.
Cause that's how we're saved.